et nous recevons ce matin christian
jacob bonjour à vous bonjour comme
député de seine-et-marne président de l
air pas facile un parti en opération
survie après le le score
désastreux
on cherche un qualificatif de dimanche
on va y revenir j'imagine que vous allez
commencer à réfléchir aux raisons pour
lesquelles vous en est arrivé là mais
d'abord christian jacob pas facile non
plus de comprendre quelle est la ligne
du parti pour le second tour on entend
chez vous des jeux vote emmanuel macron
des je vais voter blanc
d je vais m'abstenir vous ne tenez pas
votre oppression jacob jeu pour lequel
sur le tenir je peux tenir le les
troupes ces deux une question de faire
preuve d'un peu d'humilité et de
modestie après le résultat qui était qui
était le nôtre vous savez si les
consignes de vote marchait je ne connais
pas un électeur qui attendent les mains
jointes de savoir ce que va dire telle
ou telle
formation politique pour savoir comment
il va botter nous nous avons une ligne
que qui est très clair c'est aucune
double voix ne doit aller à marine le
pen parce que marine le pen c'est le
chaos c'est le chaos sur la scène
internationale ce sera le seul isolement
sur la scène internationale le chaos
nationale et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons dit très clairement
aucune voix ne peut à la marine le pen
ensuite chacun d'entre nous dans ce
cadre-là sprimont et des personnes moi
juste une personnalité publique donc
j'ai exprimé le choix qui serait le mien
je mettrais mois pour m'opposer à marine
le pen à bulletin macron dans l'urne ça
ne vaut ni caution ni adhésion
ni ni soutien simplement je considère
que c'est le meilleur moyen
de s'opposer d'empêcher marine le pen de
devenir président de la république
voilà et et c'est d'ailleurs la ligne
qui avait été celle en 2000 en 2017
et encore une fois la veux dire donc je
dis un peu d'humilité c'est de dire
combien de prétention de dire j'appelle
je demande t on demande les électeurs
dieu merci on en république s'est échoué
mais il est important que l'on dise
quand on est une personnalité publique
ce que l'on fait c'est ce que je fais ce
matin est ce que vous vous permettez
parce que vous êtes un chiraquien
j'allais dire pur sucre pardon pour la
familiarité vous avez été très proche du
président chirac on se souvient quand en
2002 lorsque jacques chirac candidat
s'était retrouvé face à jean marie le
pen vous aviez fait appel au front
républicain
évidemment est aujourd'hui en 2020 de 20
ans après ça n'est pas exactement la
même consigne vous ne dites pas appelé
voter macron pour empêcher marine le pen
de venir au pouvoir il ya quand même une
différence
donc c'est pour ça que je me permets
d'insister le violon le jeu pourquoi
cette différence est-ce que ça n'est pas
collectivement prendre une
responsabilité qui pourrait être lourde
si marine le pen venait tête la
responsabilité lourde c'est cette
d'emmanuel macron c'est lui qui a pensé
organiser réfléchi cette stratégie pour
faire
d'abord on ne faisant pas de réforme en
ne répondant pas aux attentes des
français en générant des colères en
générant un vote de désespérance le
responsable c'est lui et lui seul de
cette de cette situation nous après le
résultat qui était le nôtre à 4,8 pour
cent à l'élection présidentielle excusez
moi mais comme je vous ai un peu de
modestie c'est ça moi mon vote il n'a
pas changé il là il est là il est même
qu'il était presque 4 8% bon il faut pas
trop s'appesantir en mai s'est passé le
mai et ce n'est pas sale j'exprime ma
position
et voilà mais qui a toujours été la même
elle n'a pas elle n'a pas changé elle ne
changera pas
pour moi c'est l'idée que marine le pen
soit président de la république c'est
une idée que je réfute totalement mais
les jaurès un adversaire déterminé à
emmanuel macron parce que c'est lui qui
nous a conduits là c'est lui qui a voulu
cela il a tout fait pour effectivement
rêver de ce match à deux et est
aujourd'hui on le sent effectivement un
peu en panique mais il en est le
responsable juste pour venir sur marine
le pen je vous repose la question vous
êtes le président du parti christian
jacob si marine le pen est élue est ce
que vous ne regretterez pas d'avoir été
plus précis mais plus actif mais active
mais qu'est ce clan le barrage à marine
avec mais qu'est ce que je vais
regretter de ne pas avoir appelé à voter
emmanuel bach et je vous dis que je fais
ensuite vous avez l'observer la droite
elle est elle effectivement diverses
vous avez des des gens vous êtes parfois
reçu ces hauts plateaux qui sont un mets
mes amis politiques qui sont au sein des
il fallait sauver cette unité de partie
il faut absolument pas trop élevé non
c'est je crois que d'abord il est
important pour nous maintenant de passer
après ces présidentielles de passer à
l'étape des législatives parce que je
veux rappeler que les textes
qui doivent répondre aux attentes des
français que ce soit sur des réformes
que ce soit sur des mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat c'est à l'assemblée
nationale que ça se passera et donc
c'est pour ça que il faut se tourner
après au lendemain du deuxième tour vers
les élections législatives et la droite
ne peut gagner que si elle est unie et
rassemblée et en étant qu'il faut il
faut préserver l'unité tout prix l'union
à tout prix c'est ce que vous avez voulu
faire en votre faisant voter donc cet
appel à une affaire par anne à ne pas
voter marine le pen sans aller jusqu'à
dire votez m'a comblé et plaignez
vous savez une élection y avoir des
surprises on l'a vu
on l'a vu au premier tour après je pense
je pense que les français ne peuvent pas
élire marine le pen mais mais c'est une
élection donc dans une élection voilà
tout peut jouer c'est pour ça que moi je
fais pas encore une fois de livres du
vote que vous dites moi je vote emmanuel
macron en tant que parti je ne vais pas
jusque là non mais c'est en français ce
matin normes et même à quoi bon je me
suis exprimée mais mais mais encore un
peu de modestie que c'est pas moi qui
vais les français ne sont pas l'âge nous
remet regarde dans les yeux en l'air
disant dites moi ce que je dois faire ça
se saurait
ça fait des remous quand même alors
quelques remous sinon ça a été voté très
majoritairement
mais il ya le maire de château rouge il
avait rousse qui ne se reconnaît pas
dans les tergiversations de votre parti
à vergigny duby muller député de
haute-savoie alexandre vincent des aussi
maire de rillieux la pape qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans tes dents dans ce
texte des vaguelettes évacue la été
adoptée de 87% du boro politique dans un
débat très libre très très ouvert
j'arrête avec ces questions autour de ce
texte qui apparaît effectivement comme
une forme de petit dénominateur commun
face aux risques marine le pen vous êtes
d'accord avec ça non c'est pas petit
dénominateur commun minister cessé de
poursuivre demain on peut passer la
matinale dessus si vous voulez
c'était dans vos pires cauchemars quand
même ce score vous l'aviez imaginé ou
pas non non non je veux pas vous dire
qu'on l'avait imaginé non
il y aura une analyse
à froid qu'il faudra faire me méfie
toujours des des analyses à chaud et des
prises de position à l'emporte-pièce la
réalité c'est qu'on n'a pas réussi à
ouvrir les taux entre à la fois le
président de la république qui a retardé
cette campagne maximum que utilisaient
tous les arguments pour la retarder et
marine le pen il y avait il y a une voix
qui hélas cette voie elles existent sur
le territoire
les républicains il ya moins de vingt
deux ans fait 50 56 % aux élections
municipales sert 56% des villes sont
détenus par des exécutifs et l'air 60%
des départements donc c'est tout je veux
aller jusqu'au bout du raisonnement donc
7 7 voix
autonome indépendante de la droite
républicaine
elles existent elles existent sur le
territoire on n'a pas réussi à desserrer
l'étau au niveau national c'est pour ça
que je pense aux législatives parce que
cet ancrage territorial c'est à dire le
témoignage que porteront nos candidats
sur ces 577 circonscriptions de france
c'est le témoignage de la représentation
des territoires quand on est à un état
central et centralisateur et ça
on a besoin de cela parce que c'est
encore une fois à l'assemblée que les
textes seront votées la vie mais il
vient pas vous parler des régionales
mais sur le plan national trois défaites
successives deux éliminations dès le
premier tour il y avait sept millions
deux cent mille électeurs de françois
fillon en 2017 on s'en souvient malgré
le scandale il y a 6 millions qui sont
partis ailleurs 6 millions qui sont
partis ailleurs pardon mais comment vous
en êtes arrivés là
parce que je vous dis on doit en dehors
de dire c'est la faute à macron c'est la
main non à le pen non nommé josé dit on
n'a pas réussi à ouvrir ces têtes au
lait les deux mâchoires de de lettonie
vous n'avez plus d espace politique
entre les deux
l'espace l'espace été dit par les
scellés l'espace politique on l'a
effectivement sur les sur les
territoires et c'est pour ça que encore
une fois je reviens ou les bacs on va
avoir sur les législatives mais c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas réussi à l'imposer au
niveau national et cela fait le plus mal
à votre avis dans cet effet dans cette
campagne cette défaite c'est franchement
c'est le résultat
vous savez mais la vie politique est
faite de cela aussi il faut accepter les
échecs savoir en tirer les enseignements
à cette défaite les républicains on a
depuis l'histoire notre famille
politique on a encaissé beaucoup de
chocs on ne sait toujours s'est toujours
relevé dans ses proportions non mais
vous savez des débats internes on en a
eues c'est en soi si on remonte la rue
saint michel
barnier qui est évoqué 74
si on veut remonter on
on est on en ait beaucoup on a toujours
on est toujours réussi à remonter en
remonte par les territoires par le par
le terrain voilà le l'échec les
cinglants il faut l'assumer il faut se
reconstruire avec courage parce que la
vie politique c'est ça et est donc vous
vous dites on ferme pas la porte de l
air tout de suite financièrement vous
allez tenir le choc le pays creston il
s'agit évocation du sacre coton
évidemment ces jeux faire allusion au
fait que valérie pécresse a lancé un
appel aux dons d'ailleurs il arrive déjà
les donc
oui déjà vous avez déjà des militants
qui ont pas nécessairement 20 des
militants mais d'autres personnes oui
oui oui ça arrive vous pouvez pas nous
non non non non parce que non mais on
voit que les enveloppes des enveloppes
de dons commencent à arriver mais bon
voilà il ya une situation difficile
parce que on n'avait pas anticipé
effectivement de faire moins de 2 5% et
nous sommes dans la même situation que
d'autres candidats qui ne sont pas à 5%
c'est-à-dire que il faut que le parti
soit capable d'accompagner
valérie pécresse je vous rappelle et
celle pour une présidentielle c'est
après que l'on fait est ce que vous
allez le parti va l'aider justement
sur la déjà fait on va continuer bien
sûr vous n'avez pas la laisser tout seul
face à ces un évident sainghin des vies
de millions bien ça la campagne ces 14
millions la voilà d'accord il ya le
parti a déjà fait beaucoup et on va
continuer aller à l'aider mais il ya
effectivement besoin
l'ailé les dons sont non seulement sont
les bienvenus mais sont bien sûr il faut
qu on vient parce que 14,8 réponse des
millions voilà
il ya je crois que le prêt personnel ce
que les diverses et s étaient de l'ordre
de cinq millions d'euros donc c'est 5
semblait aidé à fonder non parce que
sinon parti va mettre au pot pour
l'aider aussi on va trouver une solution
écouter en 48 heures ont fait pas tout
ça sur des coins de table dans
l'affolement donc mais vous avez les
reins solides
là
on a non non parties qui n'ont d'accord
mais tu la crise il ya à les garder la
radio oui bien sûr il
ya une situation qui est difficile
des situations difficiles on en a eu on
a suivi faire face mais mais c'est vrai
que voilà il ya besoin de dons
effectivement vous pouvez donner une
perspective il faut un million non mais
tout ça ne veut rien dire si chacun fait
en son âme et conscience ce qu'il peut
faire et des dents ça ça peut être 5
euros ça peut te disais oui oui ça y'a
pas de pas de petits dons il n'y a pas
de petits dons étaient donc voilà les
législatives vous avez 100
circonscription sans une je crois dans
combien de ces circonscriptions et l'air
est arrivé en tête dimanche
je ne sais pas je vais pas regarder mais
ça calcule qu'il a pas beaucoup de
chance vouloir calquer une
présidentielle sur une législative tout
cela
n'a aucun sens souviens pas en province
où le candidat est arrivé je crois que
c'est jean luc mélenchon marine le pen
et emmanuel macron qui sont arrivés les
trois premiers valérie pécresse a fait
500 voix province et votre ville et les
trois autres ont fait à chacun chacun
fait le double de ce qu'a fait me lie
pécresse ça ne donne aucune indication
sur le vote sur législatives absolument
aucune donc vous allez en saurez combien
c'est l'inscription écoutez je pense que
d'abord pour nos candidats sortants qui
ont été
élus
avec des vents contraires la dernière
fois parce que la dernière fois on avait
ce jeune candidat jeune et sémillant et
cetera qui allait révolutionner la vie
politique qui mettait d'ailleurs comme
priorité le fait qu'il allait faire
baisser les les les voix qui se
portaient sur des candidats des extrêmes
et que ce serait sa réussite dont il a
échoué sur toute la ligne ils ont réussi
ils ont tenu bon ils ont un ancrage
c'est la différence de nos candidats
c'est que nos nos candidats ne sont pas
choisis sur internet ils ont tous un
ancrage et une assise territoriale et
c'est ça qui fait c'est ça qui fait la
différence et l'assemblée nationale
c'est la représentation de 577
territoire de france et donc les
françaises et les français doivent
envoyer à l'assemblée des gens qui vont
qui comprennent leur territoire y'a pas
de représentant enseignements que vous
avez regardé parce que je sais que vous
êtes un 1 analyse de la carte électorale
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui est arrivé
en tête dans ce département jean luc
mélenchon anglais c'est pas le même
profil qui emmanuel macron lens est une
menace donc c'est que emmanuel macron a
échoué sur son quinquennat il a nommé
l'un des précieux pour notre survie a
fallu venir mais bien sûr que je vais
vous répondre mais emmanuel macron à
générer de la colère la colère génère
des voix 2 des votes de désespérance et
le premier tour la présidentielle et est
un cri d' allah d'alarm d' alerte sur
cette désespérance été générés et jeudi
que le moyen de corriger cela c'est par
les élections législatives parce que
c'est là que les textes sont votés c'est
au parlement et notamment à l'assemblée
nationale après vous savez moi le si
vous voulez prendre des résultats
concrets la dernière fois aux élections
sur ma circonscription je crois que
marine le pen avait dû faire 55 % au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle
en est un opposant déterminé au front
national j'ai fait 65% législatives donc
tout cela pour dire que copier la carte
des des résultats présidentiels sur
législatives n'a pas de sens parce que
les législatives c'est la représentation
d'intéressant désir et violet jc ça oui
oui le parti ait l'air va arriver à être
unie pour les législatives où est ce que
après l'élection soit de marine le pen
soit des manuels mâcon vous craignez que
les troupes de ce nom de
la nécessité pour nous et c'est le débat
qu'on a eue hier dans les différentes
instances conseil stratégique et bureau
politique c'est d'être unis rassemblés
par ce qu'il y à la fois un message
territoriale est un message fort sur le
plan sur le plan politique on a toujours
été force de proposition nous on a
toujours assumé de voter des textes
lorsqu ils considéraient qu'ils allaient
dans le bon sens quoi des antis tas
d'annoncés opposer radicalement leur
tour des textes qui pour nous conduisait
à la situation dans laquelle on est ne
pas un pack gouvernementale avec
emmanuel macron comme l'avait proposé
jean françois copé dimanche soir je
pense que ça ne correspond absolument
pas à la réalité du pays et les
reproches que l'on fait emmanuel macron
sur ce quinquennat d'avoir été incapable
de faire aucune réforme d'avoir une
gestion catastrophique des des finances
des finances publiques d'avoir
tergiversé en permanence tout cela vaut
toujours aujourd'hui et donc ce qu'il
faut c'est éviter cela et c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin
encore une fois de 7
droite indépendante ça n'est pas un
boogie boulga où chacun va négocier on
n'est pas sous la quatrième république
où chacun veut aller négocier son petit
air ce sens c'est sa petite partition
négocier un poste ministériel pour l'un
pour l'autre tout ça est de mon point de
vue enfin ne correspond pas à la réalité
mais je pense qu'il faut être en
politique il faut être authentique
honnête et clair nous nous y allons pour
nos couleurs a beaucoup plus emmanuel
macron par une open
écoutez vous trouverez rend moins un
adversaire plus déterminés quoi avec le
france mais non parce que je réponds aux
questions vous me posez sur sur sur
marine le pen je vous l ai dit tout à
l'heure j'utilise dit que c'était le
chaos s'ils étaient présents
c'était parce là qu'on a commencé
l'interview s'est dit que ce serait
l'isolément au niveau national et le
chaos sur le plan national parce que
c'est l'irresponsabilité la différence
entre les deux c'est qu emmanuel macron
il un bilan
marine le pen dit tout et n'importe quoi
comme elle l'a souvent fait avec un
niveau de dépense je crois qu'on entre
150 et 200 milliards sans aucun
financement pour rien
donc vous voyez sujet par exemple des
retraites et on voit encore emmanuel
macron en train de tergiverser une fois
de plus j'ai dit hier vous leur nom mais
quand mais je vous parlais de marine le
pen
marine marine le pen lorsqu'elle parle
de ramener la retraite à 60 ans
c'est d'une irresponsabilité totale moi
ce que je veux dire aux françaises et
aux français sur ce sujet il ya deux
sujets qui se posent comment en
équilibre notre système de retraite
parce que on a un niveau 10 et dieu
merci une durée de vie de plus en plus
longue donc des pensions à payer de plus
en plus longtemps donc pour ça et vous
bien l'équilibré et d'autre part et
d'autre part on a un niveau des
retraites qui est très bas
et notamment je pense à tous ceux qui
ont des retraites aujourd'hui en dessous
de 2000 euros qu'il faut remonter donc
on peut raconter le baratin comme le dit
madame le pen mais je rase gratis demain
vous inquiétez pas on remonte tout mais
on leur montre comment il n'y a pas de
solution si l'on soit c'est de baisser
les pensions des retraités soit c'est
d'augmenter les cotisations dons qu'il y
ait nécessité de réformer et dire qu'on
va ramener les gens vous dites c'est du
baratin dire qu'on ramène le l'âge de
départ légal à la retraite à 60 ans
c'est se fiche du monde sait se fiche du
monde parce que ça veut dire que pour le
faire il faut baisser les pensions des
retraités donc soit marine le pen
baissera les pensions des retraités soit
il augmentera les cotisations et à
l'étendre à la france qui se savoir et
très clair question jacob deux questions
est-ce que emmanuel macron appelé
valérie pécresse il a dit qu'il allait
appeler tous les perdants vous ne l'avez
pas
est-ce que vous avez pas là nicolas
sarkozy depuis dimanche
2 oui il va s'exprimer que les
conversations je m'étais
[Musique]
je sais pas moi je suis pas un porte
parole de nicolas sarkozy vous imaginez
bien entendu la déception qui a été la
sienne des résultats bien évidemment
mais
nicolas sarkozy s'exprime lui même et il
va le faire
valverde bah écoutes je sais pas au
mexique où la tour molière dernière mais
c'est vous le patron andré d'être une
dernière question patois molaires
commandité seine-et-marne vous allez
mener la bataille des législatives là on
a bien compris questionnerait coop ça
vous tient à coeur parce qu'il ya
quelque chose à sauver à 100
circonscription combien en restera-t-il
on verra où combien on gagne et combien
allez vous en gagnez tout à fait vous
serez candidat vont décéder c'est une
information je réserve toujours aux
habitants de la circonscription donc
vous me dites pas oui ce matin
vers à suspense merci christian jacob
d'avoir été ce matin sur le plateau de
lci bonne journée à vous c'est pas
évident donc caudron merci de votre
merci d'affronter les questions dans un
an